ladies and gentlemen good evening and I
hope that even if you don't recognize
the face you do know the voice now given
that I'm normally breathing doom and
gloom in your ear at some ungodly hour
of the morning it is an absolute delight
to be here it is and and perhaps it
speaks to what this whole evening is
about which is finding an antidote to
some of the stresses and strains of life
or indeed some of the stuff you hear me
saying early in the morning we've got a
lot of poems that would all love to hear
so I'm going to crack on with first of
all the obvious introductions now Hannah
mentioned William C Card who in a way
who is the inspiration for this evening
with his book the poetry pharmacy I mean
he said he's a publisher established for
word prizes for poetry national poetry
chairman of Somerset House trust the
list goes on and given everybody on the
stage I'm not going to do this really
briefly because you will frankly none of
them need any introduction I suspect so
William obviously the inspiration for
this and also Jeanette Winterson who as
you well know the what her first novel
oranges are the only are not the only
fruit which propelled her to
superstardom and the bestseller ranks
which is where she's been pretty much
ever since and William and Jeanette are
going to be talking to us about some of
the poems we're going to hear tonight
and the context for them and then boy do
we have a cost lift for reading our
poems tonight I mean if you want to hear
a poem read who better than one of the
four faces and voices to my right Jason
Isaacs
I mean look all of everyone on this
stage has won multiple awards I'm not
even going to go through it there but
you know obviously obviously lucius
malfoy among other things I'm sorry but
that is how you are known in our
household
but so many other films the list you
know you've seen you can't turn on your
screen
big or small or indeed on stage without
seeing Jason and of course Helena
bonham-carter
indeed yes of course you are you are
I'm sister-in-law and again I can't
believe it
I'm course I'd the backstory to this but
never one I know but I was to actually I
was told not to bring it up because you
probably object to being at having all
the like all the focus on one film where
you're going around screaming we're
gonna get off Harry Potter on Helen is
left while I dig myself out I know you
suja said she was the inspiration for da
be a comedian extraordinaire presenter
writer
Mel ensue and of course from the Great
British Bake Off and I'm sure we all not
anymore yeah we miss you we miss you and
Tom Burke Tom who Dolokhov and Warren
piece d'Artagnan
oh I forgot that might I've got the rock
I'm doing well I think we should get on
to the bones
currently no on telly playing the lead
role in another JK rowling we can't get
away from her the strike series for the
BBC now listen we've got these fabulous
voices were going to hear from shortly
but let's kick things off too we're
talking about poems themselves generally
because obviously William they are such
an important part of your life but can
you was there a moment was there a
lightbulb moment for you when you
thought whoa this is what a poem can do
there are a number of lightbulb moments
I think the one that stuck most in my
mind was in my mid-20s I was trying to
cross the Cromwell Road and the lights
changed to red and the man standing next
to me walked into the road
and one of the cars jump the lights and
the next thing I knew there was a
horrible noise and he flew through the
air and hit the pavement and in the
flurry of the crowd around him was
somebody he knew about first aid and was
starting to give him the breath of life
and he asked my help
and in what seemed milliseconds
there were police there was an ambulance
this man's heart had stopped and he came
back to life and then everyone had gone
I had given my statement I was standing
in exactly the same spot but I had blood
on my hands and I had learnt a poem by
Philip Larkin called ambulances which is
all about when the ambulance comes past
you in the street where you live and
what it means and what it makes you
think poor soul you whisper at your own
distress and that poem helped me make
sense of what at the time was an
incredibly traumatic moment I think a
gin and tonic helped to but the
combination just reminded me once again
of how an important a companion lines of
poetry and poems have been for me to
help me out cope with the difficulties
of my life okay Jeanette Winterson was
there a poem for you that did it yes
while I was growing up in Akron with my
adopted family the winter sense oh it
was pretty full we weren't allowed books
and because my mother didn't want me to
have secular influences but she liked
murder mysteries so she used to send me
down to excuse me the Public Library um
one day she asked me to get a book
called murder in the cathedral because
she thought it was about a monk
homicidal monks and she liked anything
that was bad for the Pope anyway when I
got it out I could see at once that it
wasn't a murder mystery because it was
too thin and it said TS Eliot I didn't
know he was only 16 I thought maybe he
was something to do with George Eliot
because I didn't know anything about
anyway I opened it and I started to cry
and the librarian shouted at me because
in those days you weren't allowed to
even sneeze in a library let alone cry
so went outside sat on the steps of the
Accrington Public Library and what I'd
read was this the line I opened it out
was this is one moment no
that another will pierce you with a
sudden painful joy this is one moment
know that another will pierce you with a
sudden painful joy and I realized that
I'd found a new friend called TS Eliot
and William this idea of the poetry
pharmacy in a way I mean you've both
just illustrated it it's something that
you can turn to where and in this case I
mean you stumbled across it almost by
accident didn't you completely I was I
had during the Olympics I had made an
anthology of inspiring poems with paper
and paper and as any writers here will
know once you've got a book you're on
the road to promote it and I went to a
series of literary festivals and a
wonderful friend of mine called Jenny
Dyson said you're always sending your
friends poems to cheer them up I'm
setting you up at the port Elliott
literary fest with in Cornwall and on
after you've given your talk I'm putting
you in a tent with two armchairs and a
prescription pad that I've designed and
you're going to listen to people's
problems and you can prescribe them a
poem oh and I thought this would be a
kind of gimmick really and I did I was
going to do 10 minutes with each person
and they put a black board outside the
tent and you could book your slot and
six hours later with a very full bladder
I was still there I've spent my adult
life trying to get poetry out of poetry
corner and to some extent I feel maybe
I've made the corner a tiny bit bigger
but I realized this this changed
everything this this suddenly connected
people to poetry in a way in which
poetry had often intimidated them and
frightened by I think everybody has a
need and all kinds of people love the
idea of a poem for when they're really
in trouble they just don't know where to
look okay but just before we get good on
the robes it does so put you in the
rather sick and gloomy corner doesn't it
because if it is a medicine then it's
medicine
you're not we're all sick we are all
sick no one goes to the doctor unless
they feel ill we you know we now live in
a world where we're able freely to
discuss mental illness our psyches our
neuroses are difficulties in a way in
which we've never been able to before
and
thank God for that it's foolish for
anyone to feel that they can just simply
cope with all the difficulties of life
without engaging and expressing to other
people in the old days you'd have a
family member a companion a priest a
doctor or someone to talk to
increasingly we don't go in those routes
and the great thing about a poem if you
find the right poem for the right state
of mind you have a sense instantly of
complicity a sense of somebody else
feels like I feel and they may have felt
that hundreds of years ago when they
wrote it and they're reaching out a hand
to you and that's what it's all about
you feel understood and because you feel
understood it helps you evolve and move
on it's better than a drink or a pill
okay kick us off with our first poem in
the first poem I've chosen is the Peace
of wild things by Wendell Berry Wendell
Berry is an American poet this is a
wonderful poem which I prescribed for
anxiety and sleeplessness nobody ever
tells you when you become a parent that
you're condemned to worry for the rest
of your life
I think they did tell you you might
think differently about it but we all
know how it feels and the worst time is
somewhere around 4:00 in the morning
liver time I think it's called we're all
in the darkness all of those worries and
concerns just seemed to magnify and get
worse and worse and worse and there's
something about this wonderful poem
which even though I live in the middle
of a city and I'm not able to do what
Wendell Berry does I just sort of
mouthed the words to myself and it helps
me get back to my sleeping pattern so
Jason the piece of wild things by
Wendell Berry
when despair for the world grows in me
and I awake in the night of the least
sound in fear of what my life and my
children's lives may be I go and lie
down where the wood Drake rests in his
Beauty on the water and the great Heron
feeds I come into the Peace of wild
things who do not tax their lives with
forethought of grief I come into the
presence of Stillwater and I feel above
me the day blind stars waiting with
their light
for a time I rest in the grace of the
world and am free
Genet what's your first perm with you I
rather love this it's it's Celia Celia
by Adrienne Mitchell and I've chosen it
because it's very short and you can
learn poems easily but if you're just
starting out learning then perhaps learn
something which doesn't take a lot of
concentration I mean all our actors here
know how to learn huge amounts of lines
easily but once you've got something
inside of you it really belongs to you
and I understood this early on in life
because back to their old Winterson
madness she once burned all of my books
which was a terrible thing and then I
realized that anything that's outside of
you can always be destroyed taken away
at any moment and in a world where so
many people know refugees we know what
that might feel like and it might happen
to us so if you had nothing if you had
to leave if you had to take things away
what would you have inside you that you
could rely on and that you could depend
on and would you be able to recite
things to yourself and others in in that
stressful time and this is this is a
lovely wonderful poem about the glory of
beauty and the joy of the body and sex
and just the simple animal elemental
everyday pleasures that make you feel
better about being a carbon-based human
in a silicon world and Alayna you're
going to read it to miss happy go on so
I guess I'm internet by heart maybe
twice I read it by heart see here see
you Celia Celia by Adrienne Mitchell
when I am sad and weary when I think all
hope has gone when I walk along high
Hoban I think of you with nothing on
[Music]
you won't do it again yeah do it again
quicker what but anyway watching Houston
read where I'm sad and weary when I
think I'll hope us we could rap to it
when I'm sad and weary when I think all
hope is gone when I walk along high hope
and I think I think if you and laughing
on well I tell you what it shows it
shows a poem can be met read in many
ways so you're all gonna learn that okay
when you go home tonight you've got two
poems to learn tonight
and that's one of them oh yeah listen we
wait till you see what's coming you're
gonna have pages and pages of terms to
learn okay let's let's go on to our next
one which again to a GeoNet is from one
that I think y'all introduced for us yes
and who's gonna read this in a moment
and it's it's a perfect poem really to
stop beating yourself up in the crazy
West where we always think we have to be
doing something in order to improve
ourselves you know whatever it is the
latest self-help book um read it in life
will change
well it won't and this poem is actually
well they won't will it um I hope nobody
in the audience has actually written a
self-help book
this is really about removing obstacles
rather than doing anything it's about
being not doing so go on do it be it I'm
gonna be it right now
[Music]
yes this is attributed to Rumi other
translators unknown and it's called your
task your task is not to seek for love
but merely to seek and find all the
barriers within yourself that you have
built against it no it's very brief yeah
it is but it's the sort of thing that
you can carry with you like a talisman
isn't it you know some people carry
around a rabbit's foot you know or the
Lucky Penny yeah he's around a rabbit's
foot
there's also a lot more a more simple
analysis of it in a way which is Lots
people come talk to me about love and
how often they find themselves pursuing
people who aren't interested in them but
how so often they turn away the people
who are and I think it's something we
all recognize do we not that at times in
life actually the right partner the
right person for relationship might be
standing right next to you and you're
busy looking at the one
I got them going yeah do you think we
should have a shake hands with the
person next to matter William the next
burn um a couple of months ago I was
asked to do a pharmacy and a talk to
open a new office building in London oh
one of those who co-working sites and I
spent the afternoon about three hours
listening to people's problems and
halfway through the security guard came
in and he said your 3:30 hasn't turned
up
can I take their place and I said of
course come and sit down what's on your
mind and he said to me I came out when I
was 24 but I'm 32 and I still haven't
had a relationship and I said that's
very sad what why do you think that is
he said I don't know i'm i'm loving and
I'm kind and I'm upbeat and I'm positive
but I'm Muslim and I'm gay and I can't
be both and I said you have to listen to
this poem this has written 700 years ago
by one of the greatest Muslim poets of
all time and it's all about how men can
love each other as well as women and I
read it to him and he burst into tears
and I think it was probably the most
powerful prescription or pharmacy I've
ever been involved in and I think it's
time for you to all hear it Tom it
happens all the time in heaven by her
Fez translated by Daniel Lydon Ski it
happens all the time in heaven and
someday it will begin to happen again on
earth that men and women who are married
and men and men who are lovers and women
and women who give each other light
often will get down on their knees and
while so tenderly holding their lovers
hand with tears in
eyes will sincerely speak saying my dear
how can I be more loving to you how can
I be more kind
[Applause]
William just listening to you tell that
story about that perm in the effect it
had on someone maybe or it's almost a
confess Oriole role that jorian isn't it
when you're sitting there maybe I feel
as though I'm I'm a cipher or I'm
holding hands between that person and
that poem I mean it's it's an incredibly
powerful and wonderful feeling to be
able to simply just connect people to
the right poem for their needs and
that's all you really have to do and as
I said I think we live in a world where
we want to talk to people but we're a
bit confused because social media gives
us the illusion that were talking to
people all the time and we're not really
and I think that's makes us even
lonelier doing my pharmacy around the
country the most common ailment is
loneliness
and this is really exacerbated by this
strange avatar world we live in where
people put up not themselves on social
media they don't sound miserable I'm
lonely or any of these things their
lives are filled with friends and mics
and so on and it makes everybody else
feel increasingly inadequate jeanette is
William something do you think poetry
and when you do your poetry pharmacy's
around the country do you think poetry
can work for people who think they're
not interested in poetry or poetry's not
for them when somebody might just say oh
look there's a tent I'll have a goal
definitely cuz I think the P word gets
in the way I'm sure we most of us feel
the same thing which is as we grow up a
slight sense that we've been failed by
the intermediaries in poetry the English
teachers the librarians the booksellers
somewhere around eleven twelve or
whatever a lot of people lose their
confidence in being able to read a poem
or feeling that poetry is for them but
in the end poetry is is just words
trying to connect to you in the same way
that prayer can be or liturgy can be and
so forth so yes I think it's accessible
to anyone but what's required in a way
is a little bit of hand-holding and most
important of all calm
isn't there also something else which is
sometimes almost a rereading of a poem
it's the you know we want poems to be
read slowly because we want them to sink
in yes it's the layers of meaning and
sometimes you don't get them on a first
oh definitely you don't and that's why
we say to people read a poem like a
prayer don't read it like fiction or
journalism read it out aloud in your
head or out aloud if if you're able to
you're not on the bus but but but read
it out aloud in your head and read it
five nights running you know keep it by
your bed you'll get something completely
different from it every time and and as
the layers as it unless you'll pick up
and all the cadences and the lyricism
and the musicality and it will enrich
you people have lost the ability to
concentrate to listen well which
certainly was certainly affected by all
of this and in that sense one of the
reasons why poetry really helps in the
modern world is on the whole it's quite
concise so yes I do think our
concentration spans are dramatically
affected I don't know about you but I'm
often sitting reading a novel and after
you know half an hour or whatever I find
my hand reaching for that damn device
and then thinking why am i doing that
everything about nothing's changed
nothing's happened I think we have a
response which we're not necessarily
very good at engaging or being present
have you ever had somebody who's come
into your pharmacy and and patiently not
listen to you reading them the poems and
not really taken on board always angry
indeed no because they're rather rather
I was saying about oh you don't you
don't go to the doctor unless you're ill
on the whole or less you think there's
you need to everybody pretty much
everyone's come to see me because they
want to talk about something and usually
the people who begin with I'm fine
are the people of first reaching for the
Kleenex if I say I'd say half the people
I talk to reach for the Kleenex in that
way it did speak to me sometimes you go
and you'll get when you go to the
pharmacy you might get given a medicine
new thing that rubbished and make any
difference yeah well if I got it wrong
yes how much I wonder how much of it is
talking to you that's what in a way I'm
the same thought about it that's true
get unburdening yourself is is half the
battle but there is that look of
complicity on people's faces when you've
read a poem and you see that they've
taken it in and that's the real power do
you read it to them yes I do
then I give them a printed copy to take
away and I had this lovely moment I got
an email from somebody from Liverpool
actually from I'd be not doing a
pharmacy with one of the mental health
units in Liverpool and I she was
suffering from loneliness and I had
given her four lines by her fares which
are I wish I could show you when you're
lonely or in darkness the astonishing
light of your own being four simple
words for the simple lines and I gave
her a printout and I said stick it on
your mirror learn it off by heart and
read it every morning to yourself and
she sent me an email and she said you
won't remember me but you know you saw
me in Liverpool those months ago and
last night I got home to my flat and it
had been burgled and in that awful way
that burglars do my everything was
everywhere and the only thing that
hadn't moved she said with those four
lines of poetry sticking on my mirror
thank you she said it got me through the
night yes the next person oh it's
Attalus isn't it I'm going to get sue to
talk about this because I know she loves
it and I do too and because I have an
atlas complex I'm a Virgo and so it so
is sue so we've probably all the thing
that we have to hold up the entire world
all of the time but we'll even has a
beautiful introduction to this poem in
in the book which I hope you'll get
offers because it really is a splendid
book when he talks about just the living
in the day-to-day of love and what love
needs in order to get through every day
and those acts of kindness which are
often really mundane and prosaic not
glamorous or operatic at all and this
poem is really about that and I was
thinking about it actually I tuned and I
was taking around some wood to my
ex-wife in the
No and thinking you actually never lose
the people that you love even if you're
not with them anymore and you have to do
things like take them a bag of wood when
it's snowing it's true because so much
poetry is written about the first flush
of love isn't it yeah and about passion
and sex and actually what keeps a
relationship upright is the rather
steady mundane tasks of care
so yesterday I washed and ironed my
girlfriend's onesie and popped it on the
pillow and that's I hope an act of love
as well as housekeeping should I read it
yeah I do really love this but a genuine
read love is poets great so it's called
Atlas Janette said and it's by you a fan
thought there is a kind of love called
maintenance which stores the wd-40 and
knows when to use it which checks the
insurance and doesn't forget the milkman
which remembers to plant bulbs which
answers letters which knows the way the
money goes which deals with dentists and
Road fund tax and meeting trains and
postcards to the lonely which upholds
the permanently rickety elaborate
structures of living which is Atlas and
maintenance is the sensible side of love
which knows what time and weather are
doing to my brickwork insulates my
faulty wiring laughs at my dry rotten
jokes remembers my need for gloss and
grouting which keeps my suspect edifice
upright in air as Atlas did the sky
[Music]
William what have we got next we've got
a permanent called voice by Anne Samson
which I discovered in the early 90s mid
nineties and it's one of my favorites we
all know about the relationships as she
rightly said you know that we there are
so many stages of love from infatuation
to help me to forget you please if you
can sort of imagine the whole range and
I love this one because this is really
about not being too needy
you may love each other but if you if
you're if your voice is wrong you can
begin to collapse a relationship by
missing out on how it really all began
over to you Jason
boys boys bye and Sansa call by all
means just once
don't use the broken heart again voice
yeah I'm sick to death of life and women
and romance voice but with a little help
I'll try to struggle on voice expect me
the promise and the curse voice the
answer phony call me please when you get
in voice the nobody knows the trouble
I've seen voice the I'd value your
advice voice I want the how it was voice
the call me irresponsible but ours are
nice voice there's such a bastard but I
warn them in advance voice that we all
have weaknesses and mine is being wicked
voice the life short and wasting times
the only vice voice the stay in touch
but out of reach voice I want to hear
the things it's better not to broach
voice the things is wiser not to voice
voice
I suppose as well William listening to
that there is a way of communicating
something to somebody in a rather lovely
way yes which in any other conversation
might go a bit wrong well that's
certainly true and I think of course
there's the other side of it which you
know we've all learned to our cost that
it's not what you say often in life in
relationships but how you say it and
they've obviously I played a lot of bad
guys ever and I could say could you pass
the salt please darling and that sounds
like I wish I'd never married you it
just means can you pass the salt but
that's why I get cast as bad guys well
we'll work on it later I'd love to hear
you sound loving and I don't get put
that in the wrong way it's sitting
context perhaps we should move on to the
next time and William I think this one's
a one for you this is called the price
by Stuart Hanson I love this poem so I
discovered this the first year I did
National Poetry Day which was about
20-something years ago and I got a grant
from the Arts Council to help National
Poetry Day and not knowing the full
rules I decided to fly post this poem
all around Britain which is will offer
you're supposed to do with Arts Council
funding and I deftly picked spots where
buses had to stop and I had them fly
posted at sort of double-decker level
I live in lab retrievin for those of you
know that part of London there's this
point underneath the Westway and the
underground railway where the bus has to
stop and if this poem makes you think
Tom Berg
the price by stuart henson sometimes it
catches when the fumes rise out among
the throbbing lights of cars or as you
look away to dodge eye contact with your
own reflection in the carriage glass or
in a waiting room a face reminds you
that the color supplements have lied and
some have pleasure and some pay the
price then all the small securities you
built about your house your desk your
calendar are blown like straws and
momentarily as if a scent of ivy or the
earth had opened up a childhood door you
pause to take the measure of what might
have been against the kind of life you
settled for
[Music]
be my guess I guess that is also an
antidote to some what you're saying
earlier about what we see on social
media it's that sort of idea what could
have been what could have been what
could have been and what could have been
for other people if life is good for you
I think it works in both ways you know
it can be a sort of personal gaze in the
mirror or it can be an act of concern
for others there are a lot of poems on
there that are about being prepared to
risk something yes rather than sitting
your nice cozy corner yes because
everybody at some point gets there on a
border of common sense and either they
can cross over to the unknown or they
can turn back to the warm lights and the
sofa and that's that crossing over isn't
it very much so and you know one of the
reasons there are so many in the book is
that a lot of people come to talk to me
about lacking encourage almost as though
they're the Larne in The Wizard of Oz
that there's something they really want
to do in life and it might be Goten to
get into relationship get out of
relationship write a book paint a
painting somehow change in some way and
they need a little something to give
them the courage to start and I choose a
wonderful tiny little one in the book by
Christopher Lowe which which I give
people it's called come to the edge and
it goes come to the edge it's too high
come to the edge I'm too scared come to
the edge and they came and he pushed and
they flew
to that [ __ ] you vote on next that's
Wendy cope isn't it easy to see this is
this is tea towel poetry at its best
Wendy cope and sometimes we overthink
things don't we and you need something
which is almost a little bit of a ditty
but nevertheless has a great truth in it
you were saying that earlier tell me
what and tell them what you told me
I love I also love Wendy cope with this
poem and just to be funny and true and
that's rare
because sometimes in order to be funny
you bend truths you exaggerate you
manipulate reality but this has a simple
you know you know genuine thoughts
within it and yet I think it's also
deeply silly that should I read it go on
go on then when it's Wendy Kobe she said
this is called two cures for love one
don't see him don't phone or write a
letter to the easy way get to know him
better
[Music]
and that actually that's the perfect
antidote to this idea that it's all
quite gloomy it's when you're sad it's
fun reaching deep parts of you if it is
even the tea-towel poem and it works
nothing wrong with detailed poems I've
got loads of home on the auger there's
nothing wrong with the occasional there
was an old man from devices no I mean
poetry's it can make you smart doesn't
have to evoke some incredible maelstrom
of serious feelings that can also be
frivolous J's capitalist sorry to bring
all that to Harry Potter if you had a
magic wand what do you are what would
you do to the syllabus to make poetry
more engaging for people at school
because I remember it as a thing that
needed to be deconstructed to pass exams
as opposed to things that made me laugh
or feel I'd be much more broadchurch
about what poetry is
you know rap music has transformed
modern culture the last 30 years it's
filled most incredible poetry and that's
what teenagers and adolescents relate to
so sorry sorry you know that's one
element of it but actually I train the
trainer's you know I think the real
problem is teachers are completely
intimidated by poetry themselves and
therefore they swerve around to avoid
really understanding how to teach it and
the key is context as you know this is
what this evening is all about and I
think that's where I'd get to work in
teacher training kids who are studying
the moment one doing GCSEs
it feels to me like the problem of the
gauging of literature is that you're
going to have to come up with a written
answer an analysis and that precludes
any kind of original feeling or just
saying makes me laugh or you know you
have to find words and quotes and and
and support things so the first second
you engage with it you're beginning to
look at it as something mechanical I do
I would put a word in for the teachers
though I don't think I don't think it's
it's
I think a lot of it is about the sort of
squashing of the syllabus and the way
particularly ants are beginning to be
taught without wishing to get on any
high horses but I think you you coin it
much earlier on which is poetry is to be
spoken out loud and I think it can be
fun and I think demystify whether
whether you're reading out a rap you've
written or whether you're you know doing
something that's sonnet by Shakespeare
they're all equal validity and they
should all be allowed in the school
within the scope of the classroom I
believe isn't there something else there
William which even adults would have
which is a fear that I'm not getting it
you know I'm meant to be seeing layers
of meaning and levels of understanding
and actually I'm just thinking you know
yes yeah which is why I said earlier on
read it read it out aloud in your head
and read it a number of times in
different moods you know you do a really
good painting or a really extraordinary
piece of music you don't decode it on
the spot you know you look at it you
listen to it I mean I when I was young
and I saved up for my album my vinyl
album I'd buy it because there were a
couple of songs that I'd heard on Radio
one and there'd be the hits and there
been this really tricky song on the back
of side two and I think what's that but
once I played the album over and over
and over and over again that was my song
and those two rather cloying songs I'd
heard and read it when I never wanted to
listen to again and in that sense with
all art you need to give it some
attention and put some effort in it in a
way if something pleases you
superficially it doesn't necessarily
have the layers I just remembered
years ago I was in a production if I'm
not superstitious but as there's a lot
of people in this room I'll say the
Scottish play in case anybody has an
adverse reaction and a part of the
theatre sort of outreach was to go into
a couple of local schools and I went
into one school with a couple of the
other actors to sort of give them a half
hour or an hour of you know Shakespeare
they were really riotous I mean they
wouldn't shut up and
I suddenly had this feeling that the
only thing that would shut them up was
if I just launched into Mark Antony's
speech from Julius Caesar I don't know
why I just thought I've tried everything
else so I just went and my heart was in
my mouth I have never felt more nervous
in front of any audience and I just did
it and I picked out one of them's Brutus
and you know and they shut up but you
know I'd spend we'd spent 10 or 15
minutes you know going can you be quiet
please
can you be quiet so we can get you to
create a tableau about war and it was
like I just it was a moment of going
what arrogance to think that I needed to
get in the way of what we were there to
deliver and to just involve them in that
way you can get between these great
pieces of writing and students you don't
have to do sometimes so what afterwards
oh well then you know then they quite
noisy again but there was a little bit
of time and then they were like could
you do another one oh yeah wait here to
learn what did you did you you held
forth stood up yeah Brutus unfortunately
yeah on to our next poem and William
this one's for you this is called the
mistake by James Fenton I like this poem
very much we all make mistakes we know
we make mistakes we're not with terribly
good at taking responsibility for our
mistakes or really genuinely engaging
with them and James Fenton has a
peculiar ability to
you tell us in a way how we should deal
with our mistakes so Helena their
mistake by James Fenton with the mistake
your life goes in Reverse now you can
see exactly what you did wrong yesterday
and wrong the day before and each
mistake leads back to something worse
and every nuance of your hypocrisy
toward yourself and every excuse stands
solidly on the perspective lines and
there is perfect visibility what an
Enlightenment the colonnade rolls past
on either side you needn't move the
statues of your errors brush nor sleeve
you watch the tail turn back and you're
dismayed and this dismay at this at this
big mistake is made worse by the sight
of all those who knew all along where
these mistakes would lead those frozen
friends who watched the crisis break why
didn't they say oh but they did indeed
said with a murmur when the time was
wrong or by a mild refusal to assent or
told you plainly but you would not heed
yes you can hear them now it hurts it's
worse than any snare from any enemy take
this dismay lay claim to this myths take
look straight along the lines of this
reverse
[Music]
Genet our next poem feeling and fly yes
I'm very grateful to William for this
poem because I didn't know it and I'm
not sure I would have found it I mean
that's the wonderful thing about the
poetry conversation because we can't
find everything by ourselves you know
the whole point of this is the
collective process isn't it we share
things it's about communication and I
didn't know it and it's wonderful and
it's beautiful
and it's really a poem about the way we
beat ourselves up when things go wrong
particularly in relationships especially
in relationships you know when something
fails that you've loved and you've lost
and you think oh I've just got it all
wrong again you know I can't commit I
can't get it right I can't do any of the
things you're meant to do to have this
long happy collective together but in
fact it's wrong and that's what the poem
is about it's really saying you did fly
you got to the edge of the cliff and you
flew and you had something and it was
real and it couldn't last forever and
don't break your heart look at the joy
that you had and celebrate that and
there'll be people here I should think
you are having a breakup or I've had one
and it's the way we go back and
sometimes our selves or hate our partner
and then we forget all the glory and we
rewrite the narrative and that's really
the bit where you sin against the light
when you rewrite the past into into your
own discordant present because it was
glorious when it happened wasn't it and
so we're going to have this poem chasing
our heads Jason failing and flying by
Jack Gilbert everyone forgets that
Icarus also flew it's the same when love
comes to an end or the marriage fails
and people say they knew it was a
mistake to everybody said it would never
work that she was old enough to know
better
but anything worth doing is worth doing
badly like being there by that summer
ocean on the other side of the island
while love was fading out of it the
Stars burning so extravagantly those
that anyone can tell you they would
never last every morning she was asleep
in my bed I could visitation the
gentleness in her like aunt Ella
standing in the dawn mist each afternoon
I watched her coming back through the
hot stony field after swimming the see
light behind her and the huge sky on the
other side of that listen to while we
ate lunch how can they say the marriage
fail like the people who came back from
Provence but it was Provence and said it
was pretty that the food was greasy I
believe Icarus was not failing as he
fell but just coming to the end of his
triumph
[Music]
educator is animate every one rewrites
the past into their discordant present
your line fabulous next one
William love after love love after love
but just going back from if we do all
feel so often about relationships that
when they end somehow that that does
mean failure and it is such a bizarre
idea isn't it I mean we all have this
thing that you know we lived so long and
all that kind of thing that
relationships don't necessarily laugh -
like last a lifetime but there is
somehow this social pressure in a way
that says that divorce all these kinds
of things is somehow a failure and I
think we've slightly got that wrong love
after love by Derek Walcott
I think this poem rather like the
mistake and the price are about that
business of coming to terms with
ourselves this business have been able
to look oneself in the mirror as it says
in the price without without wanting to
turn one's eyes away from one's own gaze
and this is a really important poem to
me by Derek Walcott and Helena Helena is
now going to read it to you love after
love by Derek Walcott the time will come
when with elation you will greet
yourself arriving at your own door in
your own mirror and each will smile or
the others welcome and say sit here eat
you will love again the stranger who was
yourself give wine give bread give back
your heart to itself to the stranger who
has loved you all your life whom you
ignored for another who knows you by
heart
take down the love letters from the
bookshelf the photographs the desperate
nervous peel your own image from the
mirror set feast on your life
[Music]
you were talking earlier I just want to
explore this with you and them about the
power of poetry which is when you
realize that somebody else it is is
feeling felt exactly as you feel and has
found a way to express it better than
you can almost even know yourself yes I
mean is that is that for you the heart
of why a poem becomes powerful I mean
perhaps it company yes I I mean I think
the word complicity I'd rather a rather
should give some a quote by uninvent it
which I think I put it I put in the book
because it summed it up much better than
I consummate are the best moments in
reading are where you come across
something a thought a feeling a way of
looking at things which you thought
special in particular to you now here it
is set down by someone else a person you
have never met someone even who is long
dead and it's as if a hand has come out
and taken yours I and I suppose I mean I
don't if I'm allowed to ask this off
when you're acting and you are the sort
of prism through which your audience is
receiving those words there's a sort of
I don't know the challenge for you and
engine in in that communication perhaps
more so with pert poetry than with for
me it's more when you sit in audience
there's something that happens in the
big dark room with hundreds of people
that it's never the bit you think that
gets the laugh or the gospel but it's
just some bit of human behavior some
some little bit of truth and you can
feel collectively in a room people go oh
yeah I've thought that I've done that
and somehow it makes people feel less
alone quite much nicer always to see
plays films all those things with other
people that just there's something about
telling a story the specifics of that
the architecture of the human mind and
heart that if you witness it and
particularly we were to sit with and
around other people you've suddenly feel
less alone unless uniquely to you know
totally unique but also when you're on a
stage
presumably when you have the audience
respond it must change the way you then
continue I mean does it bring it alive
for you and I mean it's the sort of
sounds trite to say it but I imagine
that you perform differently when you
hear the response I'm not an actor
well I've played one part just got
through that door
[Applause]
and somebody seemed nervous to pull out
and I got away with it but I don't know
if it's the same for proper actors but I
think it's about a resonance you get in
your home with sort of quite an
emotional person it's you feel it you
say something that's true and it
immediately resonates inside as a truth
and that's what's connecting you it's
not necessarily audible gasps and
audience because I don't know that they
gossip a lot do they and they might do
but it's it's it's about a profound
truth and in a world where we're
supposed to be unique and you know super
successful actually it's finding out the
comfort I find is finding out how
mundane I am how all these things we
really feel together a different
audience every night does make it
different every night and the moment you
are in any way in denial of that or
forget that is when it starts to feel
stale and that's all you need to do to
remind yourself that there's a
completely different set of people out
there our next poem which is I'm not
sure who's Jeannette I think it's one
for you is it all that gold does not
live oh no no William this is a very old
fashioned poem we've talked Harry Potter
now we can talk Tolkien you are sturly
Iram about people coming to talk to one
and you feeling that you don't have much
to offer and it's certainly true that a
lot of people come and talk to me and
their lives are unremittingly difficult
and and it's hard to find anything for
them that they can take away to hold on
to often people who've experienced loss
of a child or grandchild or often people
who are elderly and feel that the doors
have closed to them in so many ways so
as I said it's a rather old fashioned
poem but it has a wonderful impact and
rather like Jeannette talking about
tea-towel poems or whatever this is
something that I'd always keep by my
side to give me hope
all that his gold does not glitter by
JRR Tolkien's all that his gold does not
glitter not all those who wander are
lost the old that is strong does not
wither deep roots are not reached by the
frost from the ashes of fire shall be
woken a light from the shadows shall
spring renewed shall be blade that was
broken the crownless again shall be king
Jeannette was talking earlier about a
poem that she'd come across because of
the book where do you get your poems
from well because I've been doing this
quite a long time God lost them with me
already in my head and I just found them
on the way
once Elisabeth schenkman had persuaded
penguin that there should be a book of
these I then realized I needed some more
so I haunted particularly this sounds a
bit strange but i haunted second-hand
book shops which were filled with old
anthologies of poetry long since out of
print I was inspired by Jeanette who has
a wonderful website where she always
puts on a poem whenever she's discovered
something that she loves and shares with
us and all kinds of anthologies the
wonderful Neil Ashley founder of blood
acts who did stay alive which many of
you probably know through enormous and
volumes was amazing woman called Jane
Davis who runs an organization called
the reader which helps people in prisons
and old people's homes and all around
the country with inspirational
literature so I just knocked and sifted
and by the end I wanted to read some
fiction is the awful truth you must have
come across an awful lot of drafts in
that yes
I'm draw it's subjective isn't it you
know I do you know see performance
poetry I do go and see performance
poetry every year I am part of a thing
called the forward prize which makes an
anthology called the forward book of
poetry which comes out every year and
it's a wonderful to Top of the Pops of
contemporary poetry but but not cover
versions the real thing yeah and that's
a wonderful source for me of inspiration
of finding a voice you read one poem by
a poet in anthology and you think gosh
I've never heard of him or her and then
you go in pursuit of more of their work
but in the end I was really looking for
homes that I thought would help I wasn't
really looking at the authors and I've
had a slightly tricky moment the last
few weeks because I'm delighted that
penguin and America have decided to
publish this book in October but they
but they wanted lots of American poets
added or some American poets added and
they were saying you know fire me an
asian-american or fire me an
african-american
try me this or this or that and of
course that's the wrong way around
that's a needle in a haystack you know
I'm trying to find the poem that's going
to change and and help so please get now
got to the point where you could and
suppose like when you go to a GP and
they're just tapping into the computer
where you can say what's your problem
and then you can you know well yes and
no I mean it's certainly true that in
when I'm doing a pharmacy I think I
thought the analogy would be the GP who
says who says actually most people
suffer from the same problems you know
they'll have some obscure illnesses
coming their way but my GP is
antibiotics whatever so I suppose that's
probably so there's an element of that
but um every once in a while I'm
confounded because someone walks in I
got an email today from someone who said
my father always wanted me to be a boy
and I'm not and I never will be and I'm
54 and I'm still suffering can you send
me a poem for that and I'm still
puzzling so if anyone has any thoughts
yeah well there's a really good being
different I just came across just called
bedazzles I think it is I have to
remember who I think readers at home or
Edie er yeah and that's just maybe
person to tears it was about if you were
mocking people who are different about
the boy who wants to wear a dress about
the person who doesn't fit into their
own skin
then you should hope to have so much
bravery in your heart as they do yes you
know and it's really good did you say
bedazzled I think I Anna Andrews no I
think I can I tell you what well [ __ ] if
I can borrow your phone while you find
it there you go
I was only using it for your time but
actually I've
in the in the back of a book a littles
an email address so saying if there any
poems that you recommend to help people
send them my way and I'm hoping that
will save me hours of anthologized I was
going to ask you where you as well well
how you find um if you're putting one up
you know I'm so regularly you know where
do you do hunter down new paths yeah I
just I'm going to book shops I look on
the poetry table it's always a good idea
you know proper bookshop will always
have new poetry that's out and it's a
really good way to store I also book
book shops are communal collective
places that we should support and the
Amazon algorithm is never gonna help you
so you want to go in the place where the
blosum obviously
and just have a look and ask your
friends but I think that's the point is
we're never going to discover it all but
if we decide we're going to discover
some of it we're going to find a lot
more than if we just sit at home with
the Oxford book of English verse ok well
let's hear now I think this is a
permanent you okay
oh is it golden retrievers over there
yes I really do well in in 2007 I had a
complete breakdown and it was 50/50
whether I'd be here but obviously I am
and when I was recovering I had no
language of my own and it's the first
time language has ever left me and it
was very frightening and so what I did
was I didn't know William then but I was
really doing what William prescribes in
that the only way that I could stop the
crazy voices that were in my head was by
reading poetry and I used to read it out
loud in front of the bathroom mirror and
as I read the strong sane voice of the
poem would be enough to silence the
destructive obsessive voices that were
in my head and I could see the panic
disappear from my face if you ever read
poetry in front of the mirror you do see
the change in yourself that they say the
physiognomy that the physicality of
poetry look these guys know it better
than me the whole thing about having
these lines some light isn't your being
isn't it it's not from the neck up it's
everything it's got spleen our livers in
you tissue muscle blood
and you get that when you do it and it
was you know sometimes I was living in a
haunted house and I'd never know when
the thing would strike me and knock me
down and sometimes I was just clinging
on to the edge of the boat but poetry
was that boat and that's why I trust it
and lying in bed recovering I was
reading a memoir by mark Doty called dog
years which is about living with dogs
living with loss but nothing is ever
just about living with dogs is it how
many people here have got a dog not
enough
well the Blue Cross is going to be busy
after this so this is golden retrievals
by not dirty fetch balls and sticks
capture my attention seconds at a time
catch I don't think so
Bonnie tumbling leaf a squirrel who's oh
joy actually scared sniff the wind then
I'm off again mock palm ditch residue of
any thrillingly dead thing and you
either you're sunk in the past half of
our walk thinking of what you never can
bring back or else you're offering some
fog concerning tomorrow is that what you
call it my work to unsnap times warg
I'm wolf retrieving my haze headed
friend you The Shining bark a Zen
masters bronzy Gong calls you here
entirely now but Wow Bow Wow Bow Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
every day
you don't go brilliant do you remember
that moment you remember the moment when
you were reading that in the mirror
yes and also the girl thing about poetry
obviously it's serious it's profound
it's deep but also it can just make you
laugh can't it and it can chew on
sometimes doing animal impersonations is
a good idea what you might want to date
I'm gonna coming up for questions now
from the audience and we've got four
microphones so what I'd like you to do
while we've make some animal noises here
on stage is to get the four microphones
out if you could put your hand up if you
have a question whether it - I guess I
guess - anybody on the stage I'm not
sure about about poetry ideally yeah
would that be friend if you found it
well go on have a think about your
questions while Sue tells us go on
what's the poem it's not quite right for
your situation but I just I just really
love it told me to give you what it is
or taught me to read it read it I can't
but okay it's it very long no it's not
that long I just let make you emotional
no it's just really lovely I think it's
really important as well this particular
little Junction read it I read it George
so it's predict it was not but not
bedazzled I'm a dufus it's by Victoria
riedle or Radle re de el tell me it's
wrong the scarlet nails my son sports or
the toy store rings he clusters four
jewels to each finger he is Baudette I
see the other mothers looking at the
star choker the rhinestone strand he
fastens over a sock sometimes I help him
find sparkle coupons when he says
sticker earrings look too fake tell me I
should teach him it's wrong to love the
glitter that a boys only a boy you'd
love a truck with a remote that revs
battery slamming into corners or Hot
Wheels lived a looping off tracks into
the tub then tell me it's fine really
maybe even a good thing a boy who's got
some girl to him and I'm right for the
days he wears a pink shirt on the seesaw
in the park
tell me what you need
but keep far away from my son who still
loves a beautiful thing not for what it
means this way or that but for the way
facets set off prisms and prisms spin up
everywhere and from his own jeweled body
he's cast rainbows made every shining
true color now try to tell me man or
woman your heart was ever once that
brave
[Applause]
[Music]
who says poetry isn't powerful now
there's some questions I'm sure there's
going to be so are there's loads okay so
I'm gonna start pointing to people
number one first please hello we were
talking just before the show started
about Russian poetry and my friend said
that most Russian poetry rhymes and she
said lots of English poetry doesn't
rhyme I said yeah that's right so she
said well what is a poem and I didn't
know how to answer so I wondered if you
have an answer what is a poem it's the
most perfect question thank you
it's where we should have started the
evening
who's gonna can you answer well I think
the most important thing is to be really
broadchurch about this I think one of
the intimidating factors about poetry is
an extraordinary sort of snobbery and
extraordinary sense that somehow all
that I don't know what's good and that's
quite problematic and I think that puts
people off poetry poetry doesn't need to
rhyme often children like rhyming poetry
to get them started
Shakespeare in blank verse let's face it
you know that's pretty much the peak for
a lot of people and there aren't
necessarily obvious rhymes in that so to
me a poem is what you choose is a poem
and I give you a good example I've put
in this book a wonderful piece of poetry
I think which is what people sing at
Anfield on a Saturday afternoon which
are the words from the musical carousel
and and it goes you'll never walk alone
you remember that and I think that's a
wonderful piece of poetry walk on with
hope in your heart and you'll never walk
alone you'll never walk alone Jeanette
how do you answer the question I do like
it to have a bit of meter in scansion I
must say but it's really what work of
the words doing are they carrying their
own weight are they are they carrying
the weight of the line is there
something muscular and held about it
because it's language at its most
concentrated isn't it and it's it's the
place where the thing is distilled in
into the tightest possible place and so
that you can trust it
to break under you when you put your own
weight on it so the thing is always
stronger than it looks for me that's
important but it is this concentration
of language absolutely I don't I don't
think it has to be the best words in the
best order but I think it does have to
be was the harvest kind of exactness for
the emotion because it's usually a
snapshot of an emotional moment isn't it
so how do we get that concentration that
distillation so that we can hold on to
it so that it feels homeopathic that
it's a tiny dose of poetry we'll somehow
write the whole or or even chiropractic
I guess you know you just press on the
thing and the whole thing will then go
back into play something like that isn't
it I remember you saying I'm talking
about art and saying everything in life
is so fractured but actually when you
suddenly are able to just look at a
picture you are experiencing something
that is whole that is complete and
that's a rare thing that it's almost
like oxygen and then in a sense there's
there's that quality to a poem it is it
exists within its own bubble it's it's
it's own thing it's you can you can
absorb it in one go I think it makes a
poem yeah I'm not you I do like a bit of
skunk ssin I don't I don't need to dum
dee-dum dee-dum I don't need to know how
many feet it's got and you know marvel
at this sort of you know I think that's
what kills at home sometimes a nice sort
of studied literature and smacked it out
of me in it but it's something as you
say a it contains a a beautiful truth
within it it contains a sentiment that
rings true for you emotionally that you
can take with you that as we've said
before expresses a a common conceit
elegantly and beautifully and moves your
feelings not only connects your feelings
the greater worker to the world around
you but elevates your thinking alongside
your fellow man on and mindful we've
spent seven minutes on the first it's
worth it and we've got 50 minutes what
it's a great question but if I wouldn't
even attend to
once I know what it does the great poem
does a kind of a focal shift it's like a
magic I'd picture when you stare at a
magic libation suddenly you see life or
yourself it shines a light in words so I
don't care what the structural form of
it is but it suddenly it does slap
people slaps you in the right way it's
it's refocused as you sung on a truth
that you you hadn't seen or understood
about yourself okay it expresses why
yeah beautifully summed up there
microphone number two and we'll try and
be patient
hi but those of us who attempt to write
poems do you think it's about rhyme
again do you think that you can't use
rhyme anymore that rhyme is regarded as
glib of nowadays and you can't say
anything serious you know it's not just
about one rhyme there are all kinds of
inner rhymes within the complex line of
poetry I'm front Lee I'm looking at the
poetry of rap at the moment and if you
just simply just rhyme off to rhyme
after rhyme after rhyme it does things
but it's this these complex inner inner
rhythms within sentences or within
within lines of poetry that transform
okay question microphone number three I
have a question for William I've just
bought a copy of your book the poetry
pharmacy and I was just wondering if
there are any poems in there for
survivors who posted me too in various
social media sites no but that's a good
point and perhaps before I finally
finished the next 100 forgot for normal
a woman's silly me yes why don't you
read it's phenomenal woman I read it
gopher gopher
I think it's act doesn't it I love that
you could immediately reach for that
pearl well it's I thought it was very me
too but now I should I read it please
it's fun well I think it's that it's the
poem I prescribed to people who are
going to a party it's what you need to
read before you go
or going to a poetry reading yep through
a nominal woman this is by the great
Maya Angelou pretty women wonder where
my secret lies I'm not cute or built to
suit a fashion model sighs but when I
start to tell them they think I'm
telling lies I say it's in the reach of
my arms the span of my hips the stride
of my steps the curl of my lips I'm a
woman phenomenally Phenomenal Woman
that's me I walk into a room just as
cool as you please and to a man the
fellows stand or fall down on their
knees and then they swarm around me a
hive of honey bees I say it's the fire
in my eyes and the flesh of my teeth and
the swing of my waist and the joy in my
feet I'm a woman phenomenally Phenomenal
Woman that's me
men themselves have wondered what they
see in me they're trying so much but
they can't touch my inner mystery when I
try to show them they say this ooh can't
see I say it's in the arch of my back
the Sun of my smile the ride of my
breasts the grace of my style I'm a
woman phenomenally Phenomenal Woman
that's me
now you understand just why my head's
not bowed I don't shout or jump about or
have to talk real loud when you see me
passing it ought to make you proud I say
it's in the click
the bend of my hair the palm of my hand
and the need for my tear because I'm a
woman phenomenally Phenomenal Woman
that's me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another question have we got to there's
a hand up in the middle here microphone
- I just wanted to ask an editorial
questions William and when you were
putting together this anthology did you
feel like you had to sort of stop
yourself from going any further because
it is a really beautifully slim volume
just wondering if you put a self limit
on it or if it was just naturally the
size thank you no I think I'm quite lazy
at heart and something about the slim
nature of it perhaps poetry often is
slim in terms of the size of the books
that you come across no I think probably
sloth is is the only excuse you didn't
wrestle for hours getting thinking no
this one of this one I well I did but of
course quite a lot of poems cover
similar things and so then it was a
question of trying to narrow down which
is the best well I couldn't possibly say
that so it's good because you can put
this you can take it in your pocket in
your handbag it's light and that's the
kind of thing you want to carry around
with you don't want some three volume
normal do oh yeah very good okay listen
Michelle Williams book for the moment
another question from the audience over
here we've got a microphone over there
we've got two questions over there
[Laughter]
and if we get your phone out there this
is so an unbeaten Scott Kizer and can
the panel recommend a poem that will
help us cope with brexit okay actually
can they come back to that question and
put it don't worry don't worry I'm just
hitting pause for the moment let's have
another question before we come back to
that microphone three so thank you very
much for everything that you've read and
said poetry is indeed transformational
and as a teacher who loves texts and
shares them with their students
I wonder particularly if those of you
who've performed
might say something about how you can
free students through the way you
deliver poetry particularly thinking
maybe about the classroom well tell me
what experience I suppose with you know
I mean it was shouting it at them was it
was just losing yourself in them I don't
mean shouting I mean you know it was a
doing the triple holding one it was
trusting the material actually and I
remember regretting that we hadn't just
I thought there's a version where you
just don't like you know like you go
into a French class and you're not
allowed to speak English there's a
version of you know trying to get kids
involved with Shakespeare well you just
only talked to them and I am the
pentameter or you know
I'm sure that you know there's that
exist but I the thing I thought of when
he was the question was an Isis berry
the sort of godmother of voice at the
RSC said let the words do something to
you don't do something to the words
amazing in every classroom to have all
these these poems these resources filed
away under different emotions so if kids
felt lonely or lost or bullied or
different and isolated they could just
rifle through and start in their spare
time to investigate them and I think
some kids it's having the permission to
read and to experience things and have
their own agency in a in a system that
sometimes quite driven and singular
context i mean i'd go back to context
anytime if i was involved in teaching
poetry at school it's giving people the
context first and then the poem and that
brings it alive to them well now drama
school we did similar we took a
shakespeare workshop around various
different places and weed sprees the
scene and let them ask us any questions
and we went to a huge wide eclectic mix
of educational establishments from local
community adult community colleges to
very posh private schools and it was
very striking how in the schools where
they were likely to and aspiring to get
our levels nay levels they were asking
his questions to make sure they were on
the right track to get the to get the
right answer and in other places when we
took bits of hamlet into a school they'd
never seen it before they would talk
about that their mom had remarried and
for the to get the council flat or
whatever you know and I'm never doing
the scene where Polonius was behind the
Arras and gets stabbed and we stopped
and we said does he know he's behind the
heiress or not and there and in Roedean
they all had the answer because they
knew then they were all gonna get aids
available on the other place they
weren't sure they were pretty right they
were they wanted to know if it could be
done both ways and we played the scene
both ways and it brought it a life for
them so just extrapolating than that the
thing about poetry or any literature if
you take away if you can with the
syllabus that you're you know struggling
under if you take away the notion that
there is an answer to anything or a
right answer you can just let them enjoy
it and thrive and play with it and ask
each other questions and
their own and just remove it from the
exam or testing syllabus at all I think
that's the key what she said was the fun
bit so not what I said though no but we
can make it fun I think as adults we
forget how to play and we don't do
enough playing in our daily life and and
with the kids we got to make the serious
fun and the fun series just got to swap
it up and musicality there's an innate
sense of rhythm and things that help us
in this in poetry that as we said it
does something to us so we have to shout
oh we can do crazy games with poetry
like could say alternate words make it
fun you've got to get out of your head
you got to get the kids out of their
heads get out get them stop thinking
that there is a prescribed answer or we
got it as you say we got to get we got
to be judged how clever we are forget it
this this is a piece to be somehow owned
and enjoyed and and you can discover it
by playing that's very cheesy so yes
[Applause]
very cheesy to pull it back to Harry
Potter what what the books watch what
Joe's books did is they ignited the
loving of literature in children all
over the world that saw them my kid read
them all because she wanted to come to a
screening and hasn't stopped reading
since and the same thing is true if you
get poems if you're allowed to teach and
use poetry and performance poetry that
there are either silly or fun or
engaging you can it's a gateway drug to
the may be more challenging poetry and
so it's a it's about making it distinct
completely engaging say I think Yeats
talked about poetry coming from
irrational intelligence not rational
intelligence so wouldn't it be great if
we could invite young people to bring a
bit of a rationality into a classroom
instead of everything being
so kind of linear right suppose as well
I think yeah
just in order to appreciate poems it's
great to have written your own and to
say to a class you know your assignment
is to just go and play as you say and
have fun and you know pick any topic you
like and then you can read them out and
it's by writing your own poem you then
feel you know you're not to separate
from those who've written it you've gone
before you it's not so distant craft
it's one that you also can can own the
thing you do rehearsals sometimes of a
good pursuit brother for a play where
you paraphrase because sometimes you
having trouble the text you having
trouble connecting with it and one of
the most situations I work with took the
scripts office after the first day read
through and made us paraphrase the whole
thing so we owned it and then brought
the text back in which is fun another
tennis ball and just chalk a tennis ball
it's so great because it's it just gets
rid of a lot of aggression like the
dollar to the next person we should give
it a shot idea and then you know just
fun things like that for young Iran
first of all I'm gonna apologize to all
those hands that I saw and I put
microphones out because we're already
running a bit over because it's about
time to hit play again I think which was
as I hit pause on somebody over there
it's like right which we know what the
question was was was there a poem for
brexit now the answer I was pre-empting
what I think the answer is gonna be and
I'm gonna you better answer that
question whatever might be the clothes
well for our last poem I thought I'd
read you a prescription first and and
then Tom will read the poem and I tried
to construct this book a bit like a
Victorian herbalist so that you you can
look in the index for your condition and
that will refer you back to prescription
and poem or prescriptions and poems for
that condition so this prescription is
for fear of the other also suitable for
lack of empathy individualism isolation
brexit
[Laughter]
although it started life in a work of
pros John Dunn's famous no man is an
island Passage has long been distributed
and shared as verse it certainly seems
to me to have an enormous poetic value
in power
it is also bursting with relevance for
modern life despite being almost 400
years old as the Western world struggles
to deal with a volume of refugees
unprecedented since the second world war
it seems that our supplies of empathy
and human fellow-feeling are
increasingly falling short of demand
it's very easy especially when we feel
threatened or frightened to allow people
of other races religions or national
origins to fall into the vague category
of the other these others are terrifying
their unfamiliarity and their seeming
lack of loyalty to our values can make
us feel that they are less deserving of
our finer instincts sometimes even we
can feel that they are less deserving of
that title human yet we know and history
has shown us on many occasions that only
terrible things can come from this
instinct we all have more in common than
what divides us the fundamental values
and needs of humanity are universal the
lazy or vicious thinking that would
leave some of us out in the cold
that would undervalue their very lives
based on some arbitrary question of
color or faith is one of our species
most crude and destructive trays in our
more recent moments none of us could
disagree with Don's premise although he
speaks only of Europe the wider
application is clear whatever sunders us
from other people whether it is death or
our cruelty and callousness diminishes
the fabric of humanity itself we would
do well to allow Don's words to remind
us of that
[Applause]
[Music]
now man is an island by John Donne no
man is an island entire of itself every
man is a piece of the continent a part
of the main if a clod be washed away by
the sea Europe is the less as well as if
a promontory were as well as if a manner
of thy friends or of thine own were any
man's death diminishes me because I am
involved in mankind and therefore never
send to know For Whom the Bell Tolls it
tolls for thee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen just to let you
know that Williams the poetry pharmacy
if it hasn't been plugged enough it's
out in the foyer and I think Janette
you've got some some of your books out
there as well I think it might oh I'm
not sure I've been I've been told that
you have so the last thing to say is
thank you to Jason Isaacs
Helena Bonham Carter
[Applause]
[Applause]